all right post debate show here we go we
are live right outside the Reagan
Library you've got all of the mainstream
media right over there and the
alternative media which is one and only
Rumble uh right over here I'm Dave Rubin
you know that much I am joined by the
winner of tonight's debate by not being
on stage Larry Elder Larry it's good to
see you and I should have been there as
you know I get shafted by the RNC
regarding the first debate yeah I had to
turn in three polls where I was at at
least one percent or better I did I get
a phone call from Ronald McDaniel after
the deadline I'm sorry you can't use one
of your polls why it's affiliated with
Trump which one Rasmussen Rasmussen then
puts out a statement Dave and says we're
not affiliated with Trump
so I submitted a fourth one and they
said you submitted it too late which is
true I didn't realize I needed to submit
a fourth one however they had finished
their polling before the deadline so
there was enough wiggle room they could
have put me up there and they wanted to
so I got shafted and since you can't
make the first debate how in the world
do you get your numbers up to make the
second debate well my friend I truly
think it was a blessing in disguise
because had you been in that room
tonight it was just a giant sucking
sound of depressive pretty much
nothingness I I look we'll get into all
that Patrick David will be joining us in
a little bit uh Carol Markowitz from the
New York Post and we'll see who else uh
shows up I sent a couple texts to some
candidates so we'll see if anyone wants
to swing by uh you you just got here but
you were able to watch it in uh in the
car right so you're awesome I mean did
anything did anything move you did
anything inspire you any of that well
the true winner no kidding uh was Donald
Trump Yeah by once again I realizing his
lead is so commanding uh that there's no
reason for him to sit there and take
shots from other people uh I think the
Highlight was this line that Chris
Christie uttered about Donald Duck and
Donald Trump being called Donald Duck
that was the highlight of him I don't
know how long he rehearsed that yeah but
obviously he rehearsed it it fell flat
it was stupid it was idiotic isn't it
funny when they do those lines at this
point Patrick Davis joining us Pat we'll
have you check in in just one second
not too long ago but isn't it funny I
mean you've done plenty of debates I've
seen her life just watching them with
the pre-packaged stuff as if it's gonna
land and it never does the Donald
duckline Pence trying to choke out the
thing about sleeping with his wife for
38 years all of the fakeness yet they do
it again and again it was entertaining
though to watch uh them jump on Vivek
the way they did uh during the first
debate uh one of the lines that caught
me uh was when Vivek said I'm the only
one not bought and paid for yeah that
clearly cheesed off Tim Scott he's been
mulling it over for a whole month and he
teed off on him for saying that uh and
uh Nikki Haley said every time I hear
you speak I feel I feel Dumber referring
to Rebecca on foreign policy so that was
kind of entertaining yeah uh and also uh
Haley and um Tim Scott got into it at
the end there that was a little tiff
over it didn't move the needle did it
make you say you know what I think I
don't want Donald Trump to be the
nominee anymore of course not so Pat I
think you're going to be a bit surprised
when I say that there really was no
winner here I would say Larry was a
winner in that he wasn't on the stage
and I would say that Donald Trump really
was the winner because this is really
all about can someone Dethrone him he
was barely discussed I think DeSantis
did a perfectly fine job but did not
move the needle by any estimation I have
to call it as I see it yeah uh what do
you think first of all I would have much
rather have seen Larry Elder on stage
than Mike Pence Mike Pence I'm sure is a
sweetheart of a man and a father I'm
sure he's a great grandfather but he's a
cure to insomnia honestly every time he
spoke
again I love it man I'm sure he's a good
man he's thinking like why do you think
he's doing this he's actually if I'm his
grandson I would say Graham Please wrap
it up if I was his son I would say just
step away move it along don't do it I
will tell you a couple things that was
very interesting from my perspective it
was a United attack on vivec it's as if
somebody from the RNC fed everybody on
the attack on China and whether it's RNC
or somebody else they all went after him
he got rattled a couple times he did and
you saw that and he kept doing this and
he kept doing this and that thing
Christy said put your hand down I see
your hand I'm not done yet so it was a
little bit of that going on and then at
the same time Vivek changed his strategy
and the adjustment he did he went from
attacking everybody on the first one to
not want it to be a synergist yes that
you can't make that kind of if you're
gonna be the guy that's gonna go after
everybody and you're gonna play Trump's
card and Trump's card is what I'm the
only one I paid for Marco Rubio I paid
for this I think you gotta double down
you can't now apologize on that and I
think the audience could kind of feel it
in there when he would kind of go after
them a little bit and then say well
let's just be be civil when they threw
it back you can't say that and the last
thing he called us this so yeah I
thought Tim played offense first
somebody asked DeSantis a question was
in 16 minutes Mark they waited a while
till they asked me I don't understand
why wouldn't you ask that's the guy in
the center you start off with the guy
you don't go to Tim Scott I didn't
understand the the moderators to be
honest with you I mean I don't know the
moderators I've seen them many times but
I don't know that we don't have a
relationship I thought they lost control
the first 30 minutes to an hour I'm sure
there was a regrouping and somebody gave
him feedback I thought they lost control
of the entire thing the first hour and
they almost made the debate as a viewer
as a guy that's a competitor the first
hour was super boring yeah it was
incredibly boring I was looking around
people were getting up and walking out
yeah so that that part's got to be on
the moderator as well you know I do know
Dana Perino and I will for sure tonight
I will send her a text I will ask her
what what they were thinking in that
first hour when there was just no energy
in that room but Larry since you ran for
governor and actually really did quite
how many millions of votes 2.5 million
3.5 57 to 58 counties on the replacement
side yeah got in with eight weeks left
and eight week raised 27 million dollars
and I'm and I'm honorable the other 45
Rivals come back and I'm honored that I
was just a little piece of doing that
thing with you and it was and it was
awesome it really was but it failed and
then that was what caused me to move to
Florida Pat also moved to Florida in the
midst of it you were in one of my
rallies you spoke at one of my allies
and by the way was I not drawing Trump
like crowds no you were you were drawing
from black pads it was unbelievable but
but I mentioned all of that I mentioned
all of that because uh the guy that
obviously I'm backing DeSantis all the
answers were good I don't think he lied
about anything I don't think anyone hit
him but but he needed something magical
there and and it I can't sit here and
tell you that it was there Patrick and I
were talking about this when uh when
when I did his show it's not anything
that the santis has done or has not done
it's a ten thousand pound elephant in
the room called
Donald Trump uh Michael Dukakis was once
the flattering uh Bill Clinton by saying
he's the best stand-up politician I've
ever seen he meant that in a positive
way Donald Trump is the best stand-up
politician I have ever seen bar nut you
and I were talking about how what
normally happens when you're a one-term
president uh Jimmy Carter was a one-term
president he couldn't get a table at
Fatburger George Herbert Walker Bush
with a one-time president his dog
wouldn't sniff him this guy's a one-term
president has made has retained his
Stranglehold over the party I've never
seen anything like that he's funny he's
clever he's witty he's successful he's
confident uh and he has a record he ran
in Governor great economy so so I think
everyone gets it on Trump but do you
think there's something different that
DeSantis should be doing and Pat I want
to ask you the same thing because you
said to me months ago this is a
marketing issue with him not a not a
policy well yeah he and I agreed about
that there's nothing you can you can do
what's he going to say uh give him a
nickname
um uh say that he had a bad economy uh
say that he had a bad job on borders uh
bad job on gasoline prices what's he
gonna say the only argument is that
there are so many people in this country
who do not like Donald Trump for
whatever reason that there's Trump
derangement syndrome I'm not Donald
Trump I've got the same policy so
therefore vote for me that's the only
argument
I would say the scientists did much
better on this one than the first one uh
however he did have one mishap with the
whole uh fracking in Florida and if you
go Google right now does DeSantis
approve fracking or you know not one
fracking the first thing that'll come up
is an article from October 2022 where
he's talking about fracking in Louisiana
and Texas but not in Florida and then
there's another article from Tampa Bay
talking about the fact that he's willing
to do fracking in any any state but not
in Florida and by the way as a Floridian
myself I don't want to see Riggs on the
beach I just don't want to see it right
but just say that maybe that is an angle
to take rather than say no I do support
it Nikki Haley if if you look at Drudge
Report and you see who's at the top who
they have at the top they got they got
Haley at the top and George is not a
Haley I think Nikki did just fine I have
a big difference with her on foreign
policy for sure but I she just comes
across across as confident clear she
knows what she's saying she was willing
to fight I walked out for the last five
minutes so I saw oh yeah I saw the 10
cent yeah and then they're arguing about
the drapes as if she was supposed to
return the Obama drapes or that
nobody cares what an issue nobody should
we bring in a woman because we're
talking about drapes I feel like we
should bring in a woman Carol Marco it's
from the New York Post our drape expert
here actually if anyone I was saying to
Larry that he sort of won tonight
because he wasn't involved in the debate
Pat had a better seat than me
but you had the best seat for you guys
watching at home Carol was right behind
uh who was the male moderator you yeah
you were right there you were one of the
two people right there you could have
you could have stolen the show tonight
like a little something you made some
bases
yeah I'm getting a lot of Twitter
comments and I was smirking but that's
just my face so
what's your uh what's your takeaway as
to what happened here nobody seems
particularly impressed to say the least
he's not getting any
[Music]
they're not getting anywhere we're not
answering any questions everybody's
trying to land like the good line
um I think Nikki did well Landing those
lines I think DeSantis looked like the
grown-up in the room trying to avoid the
squabbling
um but I don't know that these debates
are getting anywhere and one of the
reasons is there are just too many
candidates up there it's it's gotten to
where we're not getting anybody's
message nobody knows what anybody stands
for and it's pointless would we all
agree at this point that Pence Tim Scott
Christy and uh right you call him
Bergstrom from Family Guy but bergram
that they if they drop this would make a
lot more sense Pat you think that would
be fair and then we could have something
a little more sensible Vivek Nikki uh
look
we're in the business of politics I'll
give you my one feedback that maybe we
don't want to hear but it's how I feel
about this you know how on soccer they
have the championship the main fight you
know the main match that everybody wants
to see and then they have third and
fourth place play yeah so watch throw
them for I got that feeling today yeah
literally I'm looking at the crowd
people are yawning and walking out who
walks out of a debate people were
getting up and shaking hands after the
first time walking up yeah I didn't want
to hear from Mike Pence Mike Pence took
14 minutes that we can get back I don't
I lost 14 minutes tonight I didn't want
to hear from him Doug very good he's not
he's good I mean he's confident he's a
nice guy
qualified all of that but president is a
different job okay it's a very different
job I I think Tim Scott I believe he'll
be one of the ones on the bottom but I
think Tim Scott did okay today do I want
him on the stage next time I'd much
rather watch the four people talk to
each other and see what's going to
happen but at the same time
I think the last debate is going to be
possibly worse than this because in
people's minds when this is going
further and further and further
everybody's asking one question what are
we doing this for Dana asked the
question at the end saying look you
you're saying you're not going to write
to to knock off the show you know knock
off the debate fine because that's the
last question she asked nobody wanted to
answer you know Christy wrote a name
down and then he comes afterwards and
said looks like you're you did write in
them they said it was Trump I wrote
Trump I want him off the debate but for
me
then asked the question saying so look
you're behind 45 46 points how are you
going to pull this up and he says you
know presidents don't get elected by
polls they get elected by voters
phenomenal line good for whoever came up
with that it's just not the truth you
have a very very big unless if they try
to arrest him today I made an offer on
Mar-A-Lago okay yeah
I said if it's 18 million dollars I'll
buy it myself yeah they're targeting
that guy left and right and if I'm if
I'm a true competitor on the Republican
side I'm sitting there asking myself do
I want these guys targeting Trump as
much as they are or do I want them to
leave them alone the more they do the
more they're giving them the Limelight
yeah well Larry I think you agree with
this I tweeted in the middle of this
thing it was like the debate really
should have been one question and then
it should have been a free for all it
should have been how are you going to
beat Trump forget the Democrats for a
second but this is a freaking primary
and there was just there was just simply
none of that right I mean Santa's tried
once or twice but that was was about it
it would have been more entertaining had
they done that but again what people
wanted to see what would have driven
ratings is for Trump to show up he
wasn't there so nobody really cares he's
got a commanding lead in the polls Joe
Biden has horrible numbers on the
economy horrible numbers on the borders
everybody can agree on that the question
is who do you want other than Donald
Trump and the answer is we want Donald
Trump let's talk about the other guy
coming to say I don't know about that
because you know he's running sort of as
the incumbent this is owed to me I
deserve this chance and he's only got
half the Republican party I said this on
your show last time I was on but if Joe
Biden woke up with Donald Trump's
numbers he would you know to paraphrase
the old Chris Rock line throw himself
out the window and so what we have here
is half the party who does not want
Donald Trump and 73 percent of Iowans
want you know he'll build some of them
will take Trump but they want someone
else so look to me it's it's not about
um you know defend defeat defeating or
defending anybody it's about that half
the party does not want this man and
it's it's a very winnable contest
primary voters these are primary voters
you look at the polls in Iowa look at
the polls in New Hampshire if anything
Donald Trump is increasing his lead so
uh the question is what do the people in
the primaries want uh and from what I
can tell on the campaign Trail and I've
been around all these people heard them
all speak they still want Trump
Pat from a marketing perspective are you
shocked how the lack of entertainment
like I I get I want a competent
executive we've discussed this many
times I actually don't care about the
show that much I just want someone I
moved to Florida and and changed my life
because of a competent executive and the
people that supported him right so I
don't care about the show that much and
yet it's increasingly obvious that the
show May matter way more than the
policies like why aren't they figuring
out a better way to do the show you mean
the debate yeah just the show portion
yeah I mean listen it's so boring it's
not even funny it's driving me insane
just watching it uh how they don't want
to innovate and every single like you
know how our educational system is not
innovating it's the same thing it's been
for 50 60 70 years but everything is
different technology is different and
people are disrupted I think this needs
to be disrupted already what is this all
about we're supposed to sit there and
watch this format it makes no sense to
me you can run a March Madness bracket
have people do face-offs that two hour
long and then the winner goes to the
next and it's leading to there's so many
different formats you can do then this
nonsense they're doing but by the way
let's talk about one thing that maybe
you know you're seeing the DeSantis knew
some debate right that's coming up
November 22nd whatever the date is I
think they confirmed the agreed on how
that's going to be taking place there's
an element right now that something no
one's talking about you're seeing
Newsome is now campaigning Newsome
vetoed two things this week yeah that's
drawn them more to the center what is he
doing what do you mean saying no to
something you agreed on four or five
months ago now you're doing that the
only reason he would be vetoing things
that's more centered than the lap is
because maybe he wants to win that voter
maybe he wants to he's running thinking
about something's gonna happen there
yeah so if if Newsom comes up who is he
going to match up again against our Fox
News we know Fox News is not for Trump
Fox News is more for DeSantis of course
they're going to want to put DeSantis
against Trump but at the end of the day
you can do all you want to do if the
voter wants Trump you can try to
convince yourself and make yourself feel
happy and all this stuff that's not how
business and competition Works numbers
do a lot of talking regarding Newsome uh
Newsome of course he wants to be
president uh if Joe Biden and Kamala
Harris drop dead he'd be expanded
however they're not going to Joe Biden
if he can fog up a mirror will be the
nominee and if he can't uh fog up a
mirror it will be Kamala Harris I know
that Kamala Harris is unpopular but for
crying out loud she's very popular among
black female voters and they are the
most loyal part of the democratic base
and the first primary for the Democrats
is South Carolina 60 of the Democrat
primary voters in South Carolina are
black majority of those are black female
and they love love love Kama Harris and
if she is perceived as having been
dropkicked for some white dude like like
Gavin Newsom are you kidding me they
won't vote Republican they just won't
vote at all I actually think the party's
so evil that it wouldn't surprise me if
they did that but he painted himself in
a corner with this race and gender stuff
the reason she's there because she's a
black female by the way for a while it
appeared that
um Dianne Feinstein might not finish her
term in in California and Gavin Newsom
said I will appoint a black female yeah
in order in order to get um uh Joe
Biden's support uh damn Clyburn before
the South Carolina primary in 2020
expected a promise that the first
nominee would be a black female
now you're gonna drop kick a black
female for a white dude I don't think so
I don't think so and they can't afford
to do that they are stuck with Kamala
Harris so so Carol what do you think
since you also uh well you fled New York
but now live in Florida but I know
you're no fan of Newsome I mean what are
you he's here he's literally here can
you guys smell the sulfur you smell it
can't you he's here somewhere and I
would go we reached out to him we we did
the appropriate channels he did not
respond he did not respond maybe it's
all the lizard pictures that I keep
sending him but but either way what do
you think he's really up to here well I
think that you know I don't know what he
thinks about his own future but I I
completely agree with Larry there's no
way they're getting Kamala Harris off
that stage
a 2024 after 2024 kind of situation sure
but you know it does feel very much to
me like the DeSantis Newsom debate is a
poke in the eye to Biden and Kamala like
I'm here and I'm going to be out there
and I'm going to be debating you know
the the younger candidate in the
Republican race and and I want people to
see me as the potential successor if not
in 24 then then 28. does the Pat does
the DeSantis Newsome thing seem like new
uh desantis's Last Stand to you because
it seems to me like that's he what he
needed tonight again nobody hit him
nobody hit him nothing he said no they
tried a little bit but no I don't think
anyone's walking out of there like oh
did Santa's got hit but it's not that he
just he needed to do more than just not
get hit he needed magic maybe something
happens with the desantium here's a
question for you how does the same
mantis went from doing the news from the
day that it maybe centers it more around
him again and less about Trump
now to me it comes across arrogant what
what do you she's not newsom's not in
the debate like it's like two guys who
are not the heavyweight champions
to put up a fight and one is still in
the playoffs but he's willing to play a
team that's not in the playoffs and it's
so confusing to me but it seems like the
fight America is but put aside put aside
where their rankings are they know where
the Florida versus Cali fight you know
when that would have been appropriate
nine months ago not right now no no it
would have been appropriate in 2021 when
I ran against him for governor in the
recall election and he would not debate
me nobody put any pressure on him nobody
on Fox said why don't you debate Larry
Elder where was that where was where was
Hannity then when I needed him yeah he's
this is a circus
this would have married he had to defend
his record on coven his record on
homelessness uh his record on the fact
that people are leaving California for
the first time in 170 years but nobody
put any pressure on him to debate and
now that there's nothing at stake he's
debating Ron DeSantis it's a circus but
even if even if he's not trying to
Dethrone Biden or something like that
isn't it weird that it feels like it's
it kind of feels like the energy is
around him not around Biden I mean no
one thinks round Biden right so he's 150
years old and he's going to have to be
dragged across that finish line but I
think the Democrats are fully prepared
to do that the thing is it's getting
late to replace him um it's getting to
the point where you're just you can't
replace him with Newsom no matter how
badly they might want to they really
can't even replace him with Kamala
unless something really happens so it's
going to be Biden that's been my you
know Five Dollar Bet all along and
um I'm planning to collect the the only
way they replace Kamala Harris is if she
says you know what I'm so incompetent
I'm so clueless I've got to leave and
then they have to replace her with an
equally popular black female and only
two-fifths of Bill Oprah Winfrey and
Michelle Obama neither of whom want the
job man it's your whole life's work is
like is sort of summed up in the
craziness of the democratic party
wouldn't you say well that's why I wrote
the book called as goals California my
mission to rescue the Golden State and
say the Nation about what a left-wing
loon uh Gavin Newsom is and the kind of
policies that Democrats have been
pushing for decades California that have
resulted in people leaving the state 500
000 people in the last couple years yeah
but whenever you're ready we're in
Florida waiting for you Pat putting
aside politics how do we how do we
export this all the good stuff that
brought the three of us to to Florida
and again Larry you stay here and fight
somebody's got to do it God bless you
for it but if not through politics how
do we export all of the goodness they're
all the reasons that you brought so many
employees in your family to Florida and
everything else because that putting
aside candidates is what America really
should be about I think yeah no no
question and I and I think a part of
what covet did like I love what the
Santa said today when when they asked
the question about uh hey what are you
doing with the health care you know
Florida has one of the wars she was
asking you know and by the way it was
obvious Dana was a team Nikki Haley she
kept like protecting her her husband's
also serving so I could see that
Affinity so she was probably not pro the
santis but she asked the question about
you know Florida has one of the worst
you know uh
may not have been her who has the
question about health insurance or
health care and in the census says look
that's part of our philosophy we're not
a welfare state yeah you want to be part
of a welfare state you want other
entitlements go to California go to
Illinois go to New York if you want to
work your ass off and make the money
that you want to make and have the life
that you want to build come to Florida
do you know how much that answer appeals
to me yeah that appeals to a guy like me
I love that straight up you want to
stand up for yourself make your money
Florida's a place to be you you want
your kids to be able to transition
legally go to California go to other
places we don't want that here do you
want your kids in third grade to learn
about lgbtq and how to you know have a
boy you know do what they're doing or
curl do this at three at third grade go
to California go to New York but if not
guess what we don't stand for that in
Florida if he stays on that message and
it's a message of yeah that's who we are
yeah that's what we I think that's
attractive but the point I was trying to
make is during covet I think a lot of
people are going to gravitate towards
different States and they're just going
to feel safer ten years ago 20 years ago
you don't feel that way we can live in
California we're going to be okay today
people are moving to raise their kids so
I think California is going to get Bluer
I think Florida is going to get redder I
think blue States will get even more
Bluer I think that's what's going to
happen next unfortunate but I think
that's what's going to happen yes I
sense you're basically okay with that
notion right I mean it's what the
founding of America really is about and
it's it's unfortunate as a lifelong New
Yorker until you move to Florida yeah
and I think a lot of these places need
to hit rock bottom look New York was a
wonderful place to live I loved it you
know I always say I was a New York
supremacist I was all about the New York
um but then you know what he was he was
a white suit yeah
I apologize I worked hard for that title
yeah so I loved New York New York was
doing great and and that was doing great
because it hit rock bottom they elected
Rudy Giuliani Bloomberg continued those
policies and even Bill de Blasio was
able to Coast on a well-functioning New
York for a while but then those blue
policies came back and everything you
know started to fall apart I think some
of these places are going to hit rock
bottom they are going to elect
Republicans even if they do become deep
blue because they just can't take it
anymore
I hope you're right I mean that's the
argument I made when I ran for it for
governor uh but um look the crime is
still crazy the homelessness is still
crazy
um he's taken a 100 million dollar
budget surplus Gavin Newsom and turned
into a 30 billion dollar budget deficit
uh and he still has uh above above water
uh poll numbers so I thought you know
that in crime
during the campaign uh a guy was
murdered in Beverly Hills uh he had
armed security thank you he had armed
security and somebody who should not
have been on this reach broken and
murdered him a woman who was a graduate
student at UCLA was stabbed to death uh
at a high-end furniture store in Hancock
Park where um uh Maxine Waters has her
Mansion uh I thought maybe at that point
people would just you know it's gotten
so crazy now maybe just maybe we need
somebody who's that soft on time but it
didn't seem to matter but but at some
point I agree with you that that voters
are going to have to hit rock bottom and
begin to rethink their assumptions but
it doesn't appear to happen to be in
anytime soon in California is the
depressing reality maybe combining with
what you just said there to Pat with
what you said about about Florida is a
place where you got to get yours versus
these blue States or they're going to
hand it to you is that most people
either just at this point the sad truth
would be that most people either just
don't care or don't know or don't
understand what the American dream is
they don't understand how to get theirs
and they just hear mostly Democrats
being like yeah we'll give you this we
care we'll give you Health Care blah
blah blah they don't understand why that
systemically actually destroys
Healthcare and everything else one of
the fastest way to control people is to
destroy their dreams is to make them
believe they're not good enough to have
their dreams to become a reality it's
such a brilliant divisive dirty dark
move but the first thing you have to do
is kill hope kill dreams kill that life
that you always wanted to have and then
you say it's not going to happen to me
guess what let's just stay in California
let's just kind of Duo this this is kind
of what God gave us which is a bunch of
that's not what God gave them
but you have to destroy Faith you have
to destroy hope you have to destroy that
confidence that people can have their
dreams become a reality I don't see a
lot of Dreams being sold you know to me
Tim Scott try to sell the dream a little
bit I think we got to get back to
selling the dream the the whole idea
about doing it at a location like this
Reagan was one of the greatest dream
sellers where you're going out there
saying what is your dream what do you
want to do you getting more entitlement
programs is that going to get you close
to your dreams we have to speak the
dream language today to get people
dreaming again until we don't they can
be easily control you know it's
interesting you say that because I kept
thinking there are plenty of pictures of
Reagan here and buses of Reagan and
everything else Reagan and I've watched
virtually every big Reagan speech
forever I've seen virtually all of them
and they were so aspirational and so
funny and so decent and if you watched
him in the debates they were they were
fun and light and it was just the
reverse of all this what would you have
done differently than these guys up
there well uh
on the debt on how big the country has
gotten uh Donald Trump got a hit because
I think a couple people said and it's
true that government got bigger under
under Donald Trump government got bigger
under Ronald Reagan uh all three levels
of government federal state local in
government took nine percent from the
American people now all three levels
government takes almost 35 government is
way way too big if you run promising to
take things away from people you're
going to lose elections if you run
promising to reform Social Security uh
Medicare Medicaid you're going to lose
elections even Bill Clinton and Barack
Obama refer to these retirement programs
as unsustainable what I want is an
amendment to the Constitution to fix
spending to a specific percentage of the
GDP uh otherwise it's going to get
bigger no matter who's in charge if you
force the politicians to cut government
and to make these structural reforms
they can then go to the voters and say
I'm sorry I had to do it the law made me
do it it's the only way government's
going to get down to the size it should
get down to that's one of the things
that I've run on during the campaign I
think one of the biggest problems is
that people have no idea what it means
like the government's too big or it's
you know we're spending yeah that's what
I mean they have no idea what that means
for their actual everyday life I mean I
don't know do you ever see those
interviews the people on the street like
who is the who's the president right now
it's like I don't know
um so your people are assuming a lot
these candidates are assuming a lot when
they say things like oh the government
has gotten so big or all the spending
has gotten so high and when they take
that shot at Trump it's a very good shot
except then you need to draw the
connection why this matters to you they
printed all this money they this is why
your everything costs so much this is
why you go to the supermarket and
everything's so expensive but they're
not making that connection because it's
like it's you know it's the whole they'd
be talking you know what do we say the
10-point font and they just don't they
don't they don't understand that people
at home don't get why these things are
important well the reason it's important
is because we high-five ourselves we
have GDP growth of 2.5 percent of three
percent we should be growing twice as
fast your income should be going twice
as fast as it's growing uh your net
worth should be growing uh your own life
should be better and it will be better
if more money is in your pocket because
you'll spend it more efficiently than
some government Bureau Pat you're
shaking your head no but I can't tell if
it's no with frustration or no or
disagreement I'm like you know what I
think okay so some of us do okay
financially right okay think about it
he told me he was wearing a Fossil watch
last time I saw him but that that some
of us do okay man just made a bid for
Mar-A-Lago I guess some of us are doing
okay some of us are doing good
financially well watch this so the rates
this week if your credit score is 720
you wanted to get a 30-year loan 720
pretty good 720 pretty good yeah 30-year
loan 500 000 today
rates are on eight points one eight
percent right your mortgage payment is
36.77 let me say it again five hundred
thousand dollars eight percent Thirty
Year 720 credit today 36.77 18 months
ago
at three percent the five hundred
thousand dollar loan at three percent
seven twenty credit thirty years twenty
one hundred dollars so let me get this
straight the average person's watching
this right now saying okay I'm gonna go
buy a house how are you gonna do it and
then the bank is gonna go divide your
income your mortgage payment by 36
percent and if you do that at 2100 to
qualify for that loan you have to make
fifty five hundred dollars a month
doable we can do it but to qualify for
36.77 you have to be around ten thousand
dollars a month who is making ten
thousand dollars a month right now
what's happened the last 18 months have
people's income gone up the last 18
months mortgage applications are a lot
are the lowest we've had in 27 years no
one's trying to do anything with their
houses right the people that own a house
at three percent are not selling the
only people that are buying houses have
cash the average voter is sitting right
now at home asking themselves what the
hell am I going to do this or Union
people that are protecting our folks The
Writer's Guild 140 days this uh what do
you call it this strike yeah do you know
finally today ended and you know how
these union leaders how much money they
were able to get for their employees for
their employees five percent raise a
five percent probably less right yeah
UPS got a lot of race for them yeah but
writers kill five they haven't worked
for 148 days so then you go back to 1972
25 of Americans in membership for Union
25 of us were part of union today that
number is six percent Americans don't
want Union anymore right don't get
involved in private don't get involved
in my life anymore you're bothering me
so the conversation today about teachers
union when Chris Christie went after him
and he's talking about we got to get rid
of some of these people all I think
about is the average person today
sitting ground thinking to themselves
how am I supposed to make it today I
don't are people working Uber late at
night after they come on they put their
kids to say nine o'clock they're working
three four hours kind of a life is that
what happened to this economy so no we
need to we need to get dream machine
going again and get people to realize
listen this is now it's supposed to be
we got to go back to the market we got
to go back to capitalism if we do that
no one's saying go be a millionaire go
buy all these exotic cars but hey what
if we can figure right away to go back
to you can start a business small
business there used to be 10 49 of
employees work for a small business that
thing's going more and more about these
bigger businesses that they can control
them all I think about is the average
voter today is watching this tonight
saying
is my life better today than it was four
years ago they're all scared today they
don't know how they're I don't know how
most of them are making it that is way
better analysis than I was going to do
on the union thing because my main
takeaway was that they all slept to a
Grandy Weingarten wasn't that that
seemed to be the running Theory they
were all like I slept with her and she's
a lesbian I don't know what was going on
there
um what do you think on the economy
stuff it's like the Democrats are just
the messaging is just easier and
whatever it's like we like you I feel
like what Pat is saying is exactly what
these candidates should be saying like I
feel your pain I know that sounds you
know ridiculous the Clinton line but
honestly I want to see emoting from them
like how are you doing this how are you
living your lives and we understand how
bad the inflation has gotten and we
understand that you know interest rates
are just keep keep climbing and how hard
it is to buy a home I think that these
people really need to connect to what is
going on out there in the country and
how people are hurting I you know I
talked about this before but I grew up
poor in Brooklyn my life is still that
my neighborhood my home neighborhood in
Brooklyn and like people are struggling
if they're not the people who got
pelotons during covid they're you know
they got the one-time check and they
really never came back to where they
were before coven all right well it
seems like nobody left this thing at
least out of the four of us particularly
inspired so Larry give me give me to
give you all one thing to wrap up with
give me give me something inspirational
for people to walk from here maybe a
little Beyond just the political realm
of this whole thing you know about my
background my father never knew his
father he was raised by an illiterate
woman who was irresponsible threw him
out of the house when he was 13 years
old I became a World War II Marine
veteran uh cleaned toilets when I was
growing up started a little cafe uh
downtown L.A ran it until its 80s when
he retired he owned the cafe property
next door plus his little house we still
have in our in our family so my
Republican father said this about
Democrats Democrats want to give you
something for nothing you try to get
something for nothing you almost always
end up getting nothing for something
people need to get back to personal
responsibility get government off my
back out of my wallet put money back
into the pockets of the American people
and watch this country explode in terms
of prosperity
I I feel like you can pick up from that
yeah you know today we're at rafi's
place okay so this Armenian guy comes up
to me he says uh I said so what do you
do for a living He said I just finished
my uh law degree said how old are you 27
years old he says at the school I went
to everybody's liberal So Adam asked so
do you talk do you give your opinion
says oh no I can't talk why because if I
do you know it's going to be bad for me
I can't talk about that in California
what if I do what if I get fired what if
this happens so here's the here's the
problem on what's happening right now
the reason why the left is winning is
because a right is afraid of talking
about issues and how they feel they're
quiet I'm convinced the four communities
that are hurting America need to wake up
one of them is the tolerant Christians
they're way too tolerant they're sitting
around saying it's okay it's okay it's
okay it's okay it's okay now they're in
your face number two are the
Libertarians the Libertarians have this
mindset up do your thing listen as long
as do your thing it's good I don't care
what you're just doing it's got to be a
two-way street all of a sudden they're
saying oh just do my thing okay can I do
my thing with your family can I do my
thing with your kids can I no no no no
you're going too far now then you got
the lazy and scared Republicans God
forbid they're being challenged they
just want to kind of have their money
and you know do their thing and then you
got a couple other communities now we
need the the part I'm very optimistic
about today is the following we're
finding each other more people are
coming up to me and saying man I'm just
so glad you guys are talking about this
stuff we are finding each other and
they're waking up a group of pissed off
people that are getting United if this
group unifies it's gonna scare the
out of it we had a conversation with
Candace Owens was on a podcast two weeks
ago right after you and one of the
things was you know I'm just done
talking about politics I'm just down I
don't want to talk about these issues I
said that's exactly what they want you
to say they want you to be fatigued they
want your endurance to be done they want
to look at your eyes and you look
defeated but here's the part third
quarter when you're going into fourth
quarter your opponent in their mind
they're thinking you figured out their
scheme they're thinking if you push a
little harder you're gonna win they want
you to think you can't beat them so we
need to have a little bit more
confidence more audacity we need to be
united we need to impose ourselves a
little bit we need to sell our values
and principles in a respectful manner
matter have reasonable conversations and
I think more people are going to say I
kind of like what she has to say I kind
of like well he has to say but I think
we need to rise up and the good news for
me being optimistic I think we're waking
I think a lot of people are waking up I
agree it's why I see all these worlds
all of our worlds colliding more and
more every single day every single day
it's happening I feel like you can give
like the kind of Mama version of that
yeah I I feel you know it's hard not to
be optimistic in Florida I used to be
that college student that couldn't be
openly conservative and in graduate
school I was the only conservative in my
political program I mean it's like this
was my world but I think that living in
Florida has made it so I first of all I
see people unafraid they're themselves
and their liberals they're conservatives
but they're like sane and they're normal
in their spending their their families I
I love to see it and just being
Floridian has really made me so much
more optimistic about America's future
well I'm optimistic because people like
you guys tune in and I get to sit down
and chat with these guys and we did The
Impossible guys we took two of the most
boring uninteresting hours in the
history of humanity and I think we
cleaned it up quite nicely so I thank
the oh and the next debate by the way I
think is November 8th in Miami how about
we do this over tequila next time you'll
be much better all right we'll do this
at my place over tequila all right
thanks everybody